hi I'm Nick Gillespie for recent TV
today we're talking to Jeffrey Myron
author of the forthcoming book
libertarianism from A to Z Jeff you
teach at Harvard you're an economist
you've written a book what prompted the
the volume I taught a course about six
seven years ago when I first moved to
Harvard title the libertarian
perspective on economic and social
policy
I came to revisited I said what should I
teach they said whatever you want just
teach your stuff oh wow I wonder what my
stuff is and I sat down and started
thinking about my views on policy very
broadly I thought a lot about drug
policy before that but then I started
just going systematically through
everything and I taught that to the
students they seemed to like it and so I
had these lecture notes and I thought oh
lecture notes are sort of halfway to a
book you have been teaching college for
how many years now about twenty five
years yeah do you is there any sense we
often hear that libertarianism is the
next it philosophy for Generation X Y Z
ABC whatever do you have a sense of
students are they more or less
libertarian than they were 25 years ago
my guess is they're a little bit more
libertarian you definitely do not get
the feeling of the strong social
conservatism amongst very many of the
students but overall I don't think it's
a radical change overall they seem to
roughly reflect the politics with their
parents so there's some some
conservatives or some Republicans
there's some Democrats and there are a
few libertarians maybe a little bit more
tolerant on the social stuff then I
think was true what I want to call are
they more skeptical of government power
and of corporate power than they used to
be or really noisy I think it's noise
around zero I mean I don't see any
obvious change in the overall attitude
let's talk about libertarianism from A
to Z and and your first entry is in a is
abortion
what is how do you how do you deal with
abortion in the book so the position I
outline there is that it's a relatively
subtle hard issue it's not one where I
think libertarians or anyone should take
an extremely strong
position at either extreme if you think
that fetus becomes a person then at some
point sort of laws against murder must
kick in nobody thinks that there should
be abortion for five-year-old kids hey
but you're a parent let's say we we
might rethink that we don't want to take
a hard line against that obviously
parents we think that once in a while
you know obviously the other extreme not
very many people think that a
two-week-old fetus is equivalent to a
human life
so rather than sort of arguing about
where life begins or ends I think we
should need to think about what the
policy what would happen if we had a
policy of banning abortion and one thing
that would happen is some people would
still get abortion so that sort of
awkward it breeds disrespect for the law
or Awards people who are willing to
break the law relative people who don't
and so to me the natural thing is to
define legal abortion somewhere in
between and even better to leave defying
legal abortion to low levels of
government to States rather than to the
federal government why is that better
it's better in my view because there
will be variety there will maybe be a
few states that absolutely ban it but I
don't think very many there will be a
lot of states where it's more or less
identical to current policy quite widely
available legally there'll be a lot of
state serve in between or have some
degree of regulation and I think that
under that variety most people whatever
their views will not feel that the
government has squashed their ideas a
squash their position has disrespected
their strong feelings now you in the
book it's you you talk about
consequential libertarianism or that's
what you are define that a little bit
and explain how that fits because a lot
of people would say well abortion is not
something it's it's you know it's an
inalienable human right or either to
have one or to protect unborn children
from them so how is a consequentialist
libertarian perspective different than
say a rights-based libertarian
perspective I basically mean costs and
benefits I think that rather than saying
there are certain rights we say what
will be the consequences of having this
policy versus that policy in the case of
abortion if we have a policy of banning
it we may reduce the number of abortions
but we won't stop it and we'll have a
lot of absorbing consequences we may
have negative effects for some of the
kids who are born who might have
terminated for some of the families or
other pre-existing kids in families
where those kids might have been born
and I think that when people really
think about it they don't really believe
in these absolute rights so take the
right to be alive
hey most people recognize that taking
another human life is acceptable not
ideal but acceptable in some
circumstances say in self-defense so
people sort of implicitly use this
balancing of cause and benefits and I
think that's what it makes sense to do
broadly and that's where I come out on
abortion the final entry is for Z azuz
what up what about series what's the
consequentialist libertarian take on
zoos the take on zoos is zoos are fine
but government support for zoos is
doesn't have any very good good
justification and means more taxes it
means that some government decides
whether there should be a big zoo a
small zoo whether it should be a zoo as
opposed to an orchestra and so
government shouldn't be supporting arts
and culture more generally they should
be letting individuals choose what books
what movies what music etc their
interests yet the origin of zoos are the
kind of modern origin of zoos really is
a European 17th century 16th century of
royal leaders having expeditions come
back with fancy animals so the Royal
menagerie has always been a state
institution so what let me ask you this
what's the chance of getting rid of zoos
of finally saying to the Columbus Zoo
the San Diego Zoo the National Zoo you
know you're on your own you know that
one I actually think we have a chance
because states and cities are facing
these huge budgetary pressures it might
not be so hard to convince yourself as a
city council or whatever gee if we sell
the zoo off to some private entrepreneur
who will run it on a somewhat more
efficient basis we'll get some money the
zoo will probably still be there and so
maybe that's the way to go there in fact
was an article in the paper the other
day about selling off state liquor
stores right now of course if the states
had been running them in a profit
maximizing way they wouldn't gain
anything by selling them off but states
don't do things here who else oh they
probably will gain by selling them off
let me throw in one final entry that's
also a difficult one one Civil Rights
Act of 1964 what is why is that in the
book I put that in the book because
as a lot of people including some
libertarians think that the government
should play some role in preventing
discrimination or in punishing people
who discriminate on the basis of race
sex etc and in particular a lot of
people would point to the Civil Rights
Act as having changed the situation for
blacks relative to whites in the u.s.
quite dramatically and I think that
that's too strong because I think that
there were two things going on one was
that a number of federal actions
prevented state governments from
actively engaging in discriminatory
policies okay explicit Jim Crow laws and
that part I think actually makes total
sense it's consistent with
libertarianism consistent with the
Constitution many more other things that
are done under the name of the Civil
Rights Act such as affirmative action
imposed by government and by affirmative
action you mean quotas based on the
course not simply saying that you know
we should make an attempt to advertise
jobs in among publications that
underserved historically and represented
minorities might be part of right
affirmative action means a broad range
of things and some seem sort of quite
innocuous that are probably not very
costly but affirmative action seems to
evolve if it's going to have teeth into
quotas and I think those are sort of
unfortunate of an umber of reasons
namely because they lead to undervaluing
of the accomplishments of minorities who
would succeed on their own they lead to
stereotypes that minorities can't
succeed on them by themselves I think
that's counterproductive for a longer
term move toward an egalitarian society
you know with the Civil Rights Act of
1964 which I guess is within libertarian
circles is most controversial for really
redefining a public space and a private
space is it I mean how do you do a
cost-benefit analysis of saying you know
what there's a real value to legally
redefining a hotel or a movie theater or
something as a public accommodation
which cannot discriminate because it
would seem that that's actually a very
you know there's a lot of clear
beneficial consequences to that and what
is exactly what gets lost there and I
guess I don't see huge beneficial
consequences because I think if private
if hotels if restaurants etc
discriminated you know even there were
no law they
would lose business they would be under
commercial pressure profit pressure to
stop doing that or other entrepreneurs
would come in and serve the groups that
were not being served so I don't think
there's such a big benefit and I think
there's a slippery slope that the more
we say government has the right to
intervene for some public good the more
we set the stage for government to
define a whole huge range of things as
being for the public good well thank you
very much I hope the book does well and
I certainly hope the philosophy does for
a reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie and we
were talking with Jeff Myron author of
the forthcoming book libertarianism from
A to Z